في عام 2018 ، تم إجراء أكثر من سبعة وأربعين
وثمانية مليارات مكالمة robo
في الولايات المتحدة ، ويُقدر أن ما يقرب من نصف
جميع المكالمات التي يتم إجراؤها لنا على الهواتف المحمولة ستكون
رسائل غير مرغوب فيها في عام 2019 ، لذا كيف تعمل هذه المكالمات
فعليًا لإجراء مكالمة هاتفية
ليست في الواقع  عند استخدام الكمبيوتر ،
يتم إجراء مكالمات robo باستخدام ما يسمى
الصوت عبر بروتوكول الإنترنت أو VoIP
باختصار إنها نفس التقنية المستخدمة في
التطبيقات الشائعة مثل FaceTime و Skype
وهي مهمة لأنه لا توجد
فاتورة هاتف دولية تعني أن مكالمات robo
رخيصة للغاية وسهلة التنفيذ
وبينما يُنشئ الكمبيوتر رقمًا عشوائيًا
للاتصال به ، فإنه ينشئ أيضًا
رقمًا خاطئًا ليظهر على معرف المتصل الخاص بك
لإخفاء هويته ، فإن عملية
تسمى الانتحال وتزييف الجار
للرقم الموجود على معرف المتصل الخاص بك من
المفترض أن يبدو متطابقًا تقريبًا مع رقمك
لزيادة  احتمالية
التقاطك ولكن إذا اتصلت بهذا الرقم ،
فقد يجيب متجر البيتزا المحلي
بدلاً من ذلك لأن أجهزة الكمبيوتر هذه
غالبًا ما تكون مخادعة  أرقام الهواتف الحقيقية
الآن وفقًا للجنة الاتصالات الفيدرالية (FCC) ، أفضل رهان لك
هو عدم الرد على المكالمات الواردة من أرقام غير معروفة
في المقام الأول لأن
الرد على مكالمة robo يتيح للكمبيوتر
معرفة أنك قد تشارك في هذه الحالة
والاستعداد لمزيد من مكالمات robo الآن بعد
أن "  إذا كنت مدرجًا في القائمة الساخنة ، فستتم
مطالبتك أيضًا بالتواصل مع شخص حقيقي
إما سيحاول بيع منتج لك
أو ما هو أسوأ من ذلك يخدعك في
عملية احتيال لإبلاغك بأن مصلحة الضرائب
ترفع دعوى قضائية ضدك الآن في
الولايات المتحدة  غالبية هذه
المكالمات غير قانونية بموجب قانون حماية المستهلك عبر الهاتف ،
ولكن نظرًا لأن
مكالمات robo يمكن أن تنشأ من أي مكان في
العالم ، فمن الصعب للغاية
تطبيق القانون على الرغم من فرض غرامات باهظة
على متصلين Robo في الماضي
في الوقت الذي تكون فيه شركات الهاتف كذلك
العمل على الأنظمة التي
تحدد المكالمات الآلية غير القانونية وتحظرها بشكل أكثر فاعلية ،
ولكن في الوقت الحالي من
المرجح أن يستمر المتصلون الآليون في الاتصال بك